this is my favorite thing it's like the  movie with Matt Damon like we bought a  zoo y'all live in a zoo  it's sorry exactly we're right in the  middle of Australia Zoo and we are very  very lucky Australia Zoo is the most  spectacular hands-on Zoological facility  in the world people describe it as a  resort for wildlife because we love our  animals so much they're part of our  family sometimes we put the carrot in  our mouth and they lick the carrot out  of our mouth and it's it's very slow Oh  your makeup I love animals I don't know  if I'm gonna make out with them I will  not stop talking until you subscribe to  my YouTube channel that's right and I  could talk a lot seriously not gonna  stop yep still here not going anywhere I  see you don't walk away from this